estos dos camiones llevan harina aceite
y otros alimentos básicos para unos
16.000 afganos ayuda humanitaria
necesaria para este país donde la
pobreza y el hambre se han disparado
desde que los talibanes tomaron el poder
en agosto en todo afganistán como aquí
en la capital kabul la población espera
una respuesta del gobierno frente a una
reciente subida de precios
si recibiéramos dinero productos básicos
por parte del gobierno sería bueno nada
más hay que ayudar a la gente aquí hay
pobreza
estas presiones económicas están
empujando a algunos afganos a abandonar
el país para mejorar sus condiciones de
vida aumentando las cifras de
desplazamiento por razones de seguridad
y por el miedo a los talibanes
nos iremos a pakistán oa irán porque acá
no tenemos trabajo
jarkko trabajo todo el día por un solo
bocado de pan que otra cosa podemos
hacer
pero aunque unos buscan salir de
afganistán otros están regresando a sus
regiones cientos de miles de desplazados
internos viven todavía en campamentos
improvisados en las grandes ciudades del
país y esperan que el fin de los
combates les ayuden a reconstruir sus
vidas
hemos tenido que huir a causa de la
guerra nuestra casa ha sido destruida ha
quedado muy dañada
pero ahora tenemos que volver a casa no
tenemos otra opción
medio millón de afganos han sido
desplazados en los últimos meses según
el alto comisionado de la onu para los
refugiados una cifra que aumentaría si
la situación de los servicios sanitarios
las escuelas y la economía empeoran